ใช่
quantum circuit จะเป็นหน่วยของคุณค่า
สำหรับธุรกิจของคุณ qubit คือหน่วยของข้อมูล
แต่ circuit คือหน่วยของการประมวลผล
งั้นลองทำความเข้าใจกันว่า quantum circuit คืออะไร
แล้วมาดูโครงสร้างของมันกัน
นี่คือลักษณะที่ quantum circuit
หน้าตาเป็นแบบนี้ มันประกอบด้วยส่วนต่างๆ ซึ่ง qubit
จะแสดงด้วยเส้นแนวนอนเหล่านี้ ในกรณีนี้เรากำลังแสดง
circuit ที่มีสี่ qubit ที่คุณเห็น
อยู่ตรงนี้ ส่วน gate นั้น
คือวิธีที่เราควบคุม qubit
และอ่าน gate จากซ้ายไปขวา
และ gate แบบ qubit เดียวอาจเป็นแบบ
qubit เดียวหรือ gate หลาย qubit
คุณจะเห็น controlled gate ตรงนั้น
ซึ่งเป็นตัวที่มีเส้นเชื่อมระหว่าง qubit สองตัว
และนั่นคือจุดที่การดำเนินการ entangling จะเกิดขึ้น
และสุดท้ายคุณจะมีการวัดผลและ classical output
และที่สำคัญมากคือคุณรัน circuit หลายครั้ง
เพื่อได้ผลลัพธ์ด้วยแนวคิดเรื่อง shots
โดย shot counter คือจำนวนครั้ง
ที่ต้องทำซ้ำการประมวลผลเพื่อให้ได้ผลลัพธ์
ทีนี้
หน้าตาเป็นยังไง
มาดูกันว่า two-bit มีลักษณะแบบไหน
นั่นคือภาพที่ผมแสดงก่อนหน้านี้ใช่ไหม ที่แสดงการเปลี่ยน phase
และผมแสดง operation แบบ S ที่ทำการหมุนนั้น
ซึ่งช่วยให้ทำ interference operation ได้
งั้นลองเปรียบเทียบระหว่าง classical circuit
กับ quantum circuit ใน classical circuit นั้น
สิ่งที่คุณจะเห็นคือไม่มีโทนสีฟ้าเลย
ไม่มีการหมุน ทุกอย่างที่นี่เป็นสีชมพู
และคุณได้แค่ state เดี่ยวๆ
ที่เห็นในพื้นที่ windows fear ของ gate เหล่านี้
แต่สังเกตความแตกต่างที่ชัดเจน
เมื่อเราลงมือสร้าง quantum circuit จริงๆ
นี่คือ circuit จริงที่เรารันบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมของเรา
ซึ่งคุณสามารถลองเองได้ด้วย
circuit ที่เราจะสร้างขึ้น
ด้วยการรวมกัน gate ต่างๆ
จะสร้าง amplitude เชิงซ้อนแบบเต็มรูปแบบ
ภาพที่ผมเคยแสดงให้คุณดู
ก่อนหน้านี้ ทำไมถึงสำคัญ
เพราะตอนนี้เราสร้างความสัมพันธ์เชิงซ้อนเหล่านี้ได้
ระหว่าง qubit ในแง่ของ phase ต่างๆ
และ entanglement แล้วผ่านการวัดผล
เราก็สามารถ collapse ปริมาณการคำนวณมหาศาล
ที่เกิดขึ้นภายในลงเหลือ
คำตอบที่สำคัญ
และนั่นแหละคือวิธีที่เราได้
ถึงคำตอบ ถ้าวางเคียงกัน แค่มองด้วยตา
คุณก็รู้สึกได้ว่า classical circuit นั้น
ไม่มีทางเข้าถึงพื้นที่การคำนวณอันกว้างใหญ่
ที่ quantum circuit ทำได้เลย
นั่นแหละที่ให้ความรู้สึกว่า
เราเข้าถึง state ขนาดใหญ่ได้อย่างอุดมสมบูรณ์แค่ไหน
และสิ่งที่สวยงามก็คือเราสามารถ
มี circuit หลายประเภทเพื่อ
ทำหน้าที่ต่างๆ ได้
ยกตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ circuit
ที่ออกแบบมาเพื่อจำลองความเสี่ยงทางการเงิน
นี่คือตัวอย่างของ circuit
ที่ใช้ในการค้นหาและแก้ปัญหาการ optimize
และนี่คือตัวอย่างของ circuit ที่ใช้ในการ
จำลองโมเลกุล ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งสำคัญ
ที่ต้องจำคือคุณสามารถออกแบบ circuit ที่แตกต่างกัน
สำหรับแต่ละแอปพลิเคชัน
circuit ที่เราออกแบบจะถูกเก็บไว้
ในรูปแบบซอฟต์แวร์และเก็บรักษาเป็นซอฟต์แวร์
และในกรณีของเราเราเก็บไว้ใน Qiskit
ซึ่งเป็น open source development kit สำหรับ quantum computing ของเรา
นี่เป็นหนึ่งใน software framework
สำหรับ quantum computing ที่ได้รับความนิยมมากที่สุด
และลองนึกภาพการสร้าง
libraries ของ circuit ที่ฝังอยู่ใน
โปรแกรม classical ที่รวมเอาความสามารถที่ดีที่สุดของ classical programming
และพลังที่ดีที่สุดของควอนตัมเข้าไว้ด้วยกัน